as beyonce said if you like it but it
doesn't work then you should have put a
patch on it and that's just what
Bethesda has done for Fallout 4 because
patch 1.2 is out now for pc and ps4 and
later this week for xbox one after
launching earlier this week on pc the
first patch for Bethesda's fallout 4
arrived today for playstation 4 the
update is about five hundred and five
megabytes big according to online
reports it's expected to launch for xbox
one later in the week Bethesda said in a
tweet the 1.2 patch notes include bug
fixes for things like players getting
stuck in terminals and another issue
involving the when freedom calls quest
the update also delivers general memory
and stability improvements as well as a
fix for crashes that triggered when
jumping in the water the fallout 1.2
patch also includes some pcs specific
features and improvements so make sure
to check gamespot com for a full list of
updates for your computer is there
anything you'd like to see patched out
let us know in the comments I'm Kate you
can find me on Twitter at how not to
draw and thanks for watching